welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Mandalorian heads from the
beginning taken on the ambitious task of
contextualizing and deepening the lore
of the Star Wars sequel Trilogy era the
way day poloni and his team did for the
prequel trilogy with clone wars and a
number of other titles the latest
episode of the Mandalorian was the
biggest leap yet in that direction with
Dr Pershing on Corsa and the post-empire
amnesty program struggling to continue
his cloning research and getting caught
in the web of a greater conspiracy of
ongoing Imperial Photon fizzled drinking
what's going on with the new Republic
right now and how will this connect to
the force awakens The Last Jedi and the
rise of Skywalker and is there any hope
of Happiness we're Connecting the Dots
here in the Star Wars timeline and it
looks like bad batch is also playing a
role in that so I'm tag teaming this
with my Wikileaks co-host Tommy bechtold
tag me in baby are you kidding me a
little bonus Wookie treat for my Wookie
freaks you better believe I'm ready to
talk about this thank the maker hey
Tommy and I are going to be live at
WonderCon in Anaheim this Friday March
24th at 2 30 PM come hang out with us
it's gonna be a blast you know what
follow the west of the local Dave and
Busters and let's get blasted
oh my God we're gonna have too much fun
too much and reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive this
Friday it's gonna be my analysis of the
1989 Batman and the best way to support
our growing Network at new rockstars is
to get some of our merch and nerd
riot.shop okay Tommy really the best
canonical sources of this period in Star
Wars history are Chuck windig's
aftermath and Claudia Gray's bloodline
aftermath focuses on the origins of the
new republic government shortly after
the battle of Endor bloodline focuses on
the later stages of the new Republic
from the perspective of Leia Organa six
years before the force awakens as she
had split away from her political
position to form the resistance there's
also the game Battlefront 2 which shows
Palpatine's posthumous operation Cinder
so chapter 19 the Mandalorian visits the
Monument Park on Coruscant which the
opening scene of aftermath actually
takes place in this is where the
celebration we saw on course on led to a
riot in this park between Rebel
supporters and Imperial loyalists so
Tommy things aren't entirely settled
well that's kind of like real life Eric
you know oftentimes just because a war
ends doesn't mean that the people
involved in the war are over it you know
there's that story of the Japanese
soldier who stayed out in the woods for
like 40 years after World War II
refusing to believe that anyone in Japan
would ever surrender very true now this
period in history was followed by the
activation of operation Cinder
Palpatine's plan from a previously
recorded order to Scorch the surfaces of
Naboo and other planets in these climate
disruption arrays but that gets stopped
so long as you know you don't suck too
much at the game now Coruscant is no
longer the seat of government at this
period in Star Wars history that
protocol Droid in chapter 12 in the
Navarro School explained
[Music]
on the planet
and I think the fact that chapter 17
came back to this school tells us that
that protocol Droid needs to be able to
speak some truth now chandrilla is the
Homeworld of Senator Mon mothma who he
hung out quite a bit with an Andor and
she becomes the new Republic's first
Chancellor during this period a mother
to many people but the one person she
couldn't be a great mother to was her
own daughter that's right yeah Cliff
sucks with her creepy Girl Scout Troop
after we forget now this episode of
Mando also hits at that in pershing's
Wikipedia tablet defining Coruscant as
an ecumenopolist one of many planets
covered in urban cityscapes referring to
hosnian Prime the future seat of
government of the new Republic by the
time of the force awakens and currently
we're seeing the new Republic's amnesty
program where former Imperials like Dr
Pershing and Elia Kane are recruited
into a parole system Allah Operation
Paperclip where they have to Archive
decommission and delete Imperial
Hardware this includes still intact
Imperial Star Destroyers and purchasing
supervisors says that they're still in
the Press this is decommissioning the
alliance Fleet meaning Admiral ackbar's
Navy from Return of the Jedi it's being
put out to pasture the fact that all
this is so poorly run and the people of
course not are so willing to forgive the
sins of the past just tells us how
vulnerable the new Republic is and why
didn't Jaron is so skeptical of them in
chapter 17. what came of Gideon
he was sent off to a New Republic War
tribe you know he stops
you can hear from under a bescar helmet
kind of Scar I'm just thinking of Paul
Rudd from what Hot American Summer when
he has to go pick up the trash
so Leia Organa she spent the years after
the battle of Endor actually training
with Luke in the ways of the force with
lightsaber combat we saw that in the
rise of Skywalker that beautiful DH
flashback she gives birth to Ben Solo in
five ABY so he's currently a kid in Star
Wars history who will soon be brought to
the school that we saw Luke building in
chapter six of the book of Boba Fett
after grogu left the Saved by the Bell
new class is gonna include a young Ben
solo and you know it's like this is the
thing that is great about Star Wars
however you feel about the sequel
Trilogy Ben solo will have a place in
these shows I have a feeling there'll be
a young actor cast as young Ben solo and
we'll have to go through the Heartbreak
of knowing eventually he's gonna break
bad and become kylo Ren just like we did
in the prequels they don't care they
exist only to rip our hearts out Eric so
long as when uh Luke Skywalker calls
attendance he goes Ben Ben yes
Ben yes um so Leia returns to public
life in the decade before the force
awakens when the new Republic will come
under political factionalism between the
centrists who want to trust central
government strong military and the
populists who prefer local governments
and Leia campaigns with the populists to
become the position is now called first
Senator but her campaign is doomed when
it's revealed that she was Darth Vader's
daughter that was a secret all the way
until then people didn't know people
didn't know do you think this is bad for
Ivanka
tune in in a spin-off channel that will
never exist on new Rockstar's Network
probably
leaves at this point to form the
resistance but long before this
Palpatine had been conspiring with
cloners to generate strand casts with
midichlorian Rich blood that he could
transfer its Consciousness into and
clone himself after his death this would
be carried out by The Sith Eternal cult
on the planet of exagol creating stray
casts like snoke we saw snoke getting
some wrinkles in one of those tanks on
exagol as well as Palpatine's son Rey's
father who didn't look the half bad if
he asked me good looking clone pretty
good clone now at first we wondered if
grogu could be a clone of Yoda but
chapter 7 of Mandalorian shut that down
I think it might be a strand cast I
don't think it was engineered I've
worked in the gene Farms this one looks
evolved too ugly Pershing wanted grogu
for his high end count blood one of the
best fixes they made to any uh era of
Star Wars uh trilogies after the
original trilogy changing midichlorine
to just m count keep it simple but he
reported this in chapter 12 and that
recording in that Imperial based on
Navarro where they found another Oak
look-alike figure in a tank the report
says replicated the results of the
subsequent trials which also resulted in
catastrophic failure there were
promising effects for an entire
Fortnight but then sadly the body
rejected the blood I highly doubt we'll
find a donor with a higher imp count
though I recommend that we suspend all
experimentation I fear that the
volunteer will meet the same regrettable
fate if we proceed with the transfusion
unfortunately we have exhausted our
initial supply of blood the child is
small and I was only able to harvest a
limited amount without killing him if
these experiments are to continue as
requested we would again require access
to the donor and Pershing actually hints
at the same thing in the recent
Mandalorian chapter 19. the first casts
rejected the formula almost immediately
now when you
've been watching it you need some merch
to commemorate the occasion and nerd
riots got you covered if the finale of
The Last of Us left you hungry for more
pick up a lunch of us tea available in
cream or black featuring the logo of
Todd's Steakhouse from episode 8 of the
series don't eat there though just don't
do that unless you're a cannibal in
which case Bon Appetit if you're stoked
for the upcoming John Wick movie nerd
Riot has a whole line of John Wick's
shirts to make you feel like you've got
a seat at the high table there's the
Baba Yaga tea the gun Chuck's tea and a
tea for the high table itself
proclaiming I have served I will be of
service get them now and you'll be able
to wear them to opening night and then
also the next weekend when you see John
Wick chapter 4 for the second time and
of course if you're obsessing over the
Mandalorian right now there's a whole
line of Mando merch in the way
collection with tease beanies hats and
even stuff for kids to get your hands on
the merch you need head to nerd
riot.shop today join the riot over at
nerdriot.shop now Tommy you've been
following bad batch where there's a
subplot this season that seems to be
showing us the origin of this whole
genetic research process from the
Imperial era when Palpatine was at the
height of his power tell us what's going
on believe it all the bad boys watching
bad batch these days but for those of
you not watching the bad batch shame on
you a curse on your house however I'm
feeling nice today so let me catch up on
what's going on season one ended very
dramatically with Grandma Tarkin and
vice admiral Rampart executing the
bombardment of the poker City all of the
Camino and research facilities were
washed away in the sea along with the
majority of the cabin Owens because they
have those long necks I wish they could
just stick out of the water and breathe
we're waiting save us but no so where is
Namaste right now well say was
transported to an imperial facility on
Mount Tantus on the planet Weyland named
for the Alien movies the Easter egg for
you however during the summer months
following the fall of Camino now say
refuse to work for the Empire claiming
that after the destruction of her
civilization she would not serve the
interests of the emperor now we learn in
season 2 episode 11 metamorphosis a
great episode a horror movie homage in
the middle of the bad batch delicious
watch it just for that but in order to
forced her to resume her work the
scientist was Hemlock had the former
prime minister Lama Sue who had
previously been on Coruscant transferred
to Weyland there in exchange for his
freedom Lama Sue declared there was only
one way to convince the kamino and
scientists to collaborate and that was
to locate a specific clone
Omega so now this Dr Hemlock seems
obsessed with the next step including
technology as he also transfers
Crosshair after he's literally arrested
for killing an imperial officer so it's
like he gets him out of what would
certainly be execution or
decommissioning and gets him in his
facility so I think this Dr Hemlock
maybe uh I would say in League with
sheave all Achievers shiver me timbers
so to connect all these dots here when
the Empire took over they bombed kamino
to destroy all the other cloning
operations but they took nalasay and
Lama Sue to derive whatever knowledge
they can grogu was a secret younglin in
the Jedi Temple during Order 66 he
escaped he was lost recovered by Mando
brought to mount Gideon's forces to
harvest his blood to use in Pershing
strandcast EXP pyramids a process that
will eventually lead to snoke a puppet a
Palpatine a palpi puppy so a few
questions for you Tommy is Alaya Kane a
grown-up Omega Katie O'Brien looks like
she could be to wear more since kid's
sister what do you think she does
definitely and she has just this there's
something just I mean aside from the
sinister-ness of her there's just
something about her that you can't help
but feel like she's significant like not
just the treachery there's just
something in that performance where
you're like yeah the choices like we
talked about it on Wikileaks last week
the choices she's making I feel like the
payoff has to be she's significant in
some way having her be another clone
would be incredible I think I mean a
live-action clone that is you know
connected to the bad batch world would
be really really amazing it'd be a
pretty sad bummer for the fate of Omega
the Omega that we know in bad batch if
she ends up just working for the imps
again but it's true from Graces have
happened in Star Wars you know we can
all be seduced by dark sides I for you
know for a little while was uh selling
vacuum cleaners door to door I didn't
want to do that but the good people had
uh shift these vacuums they paid me well
they paid me well they kept my wife
alive
you keep my wife alive one one final
question Tommy so pershing's Wikipedia
tablet cuts off before saying which
planet was closest to the Deep core in
the center of the Galaxy and we know
from Star Wars maps that it's bis
Palpatine's hidden Throne World which is
not far from tython which is where grogu
called Luke Skywalker in chapter 14.
could Palpatine nearby have intercepted
that call from the planet bits and use
this geolocation to locate group school
which is where through the voice of
snoke he will attract Ben solo by
striking at school with lightning and
then drawing Ben to the dark side hell
yes Eric that makes perfect sense
because like we learned in one division
who's been messing with all along it was
Palpatine
there's always one step ahead of the
competition even as a ghoul even as a
ghost he's like oh two-way radio from
grogu yeah okay I'm gonna come uh I'm
gonna come figure out what all Luke is
up to actually threw me down a shaft I'm
gonna go take his nephew and convince
his nephew that Luke tried to kill him
spoilers for the sequels if you haven't
seen them yes I think when you mention
best first of all my mind went to bisque
I got a little hungry then I got over it
and I said yes the little like I get his
picture like Palpatine floating around
this like just cruising around the world
everything whipping by him he's just
wind in his hair his little wisps of
white hair and then he's like
a fouling calling out to me and then and
then thus Begins the events that lead us
to the new Trilogy yes it makes perfect
sense I'm bullish on this I'm hitting by
on this it's best baby it was always
this yeah I I think really what happened
was Palpatine's like that one amateur
radio guy who intercepted the call
between uh between Charles and Camilla
Parker Bowles the things uh tampon call
that nearly brought down the royal
family and probably should have would
have spared a lot of people a lot of
pain had that just been the final nail
in the coffin uh anyway hey watch the
crowd that's such a funny reference
that we would end up there we need to do
some Crown Downs anyways hey reminder to
join us at WonderCon this Friday March
24th at 2 30 p.m you can support us by
grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
like the shirt and Tommy's got the John
Wick shirt the Baba Yaga shirt I'm
wearing our grogu shirt from our the way
collection they're great please
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive you can follow me follow Tommy and
Tommy back told follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching and we'll see you this week
when we talk about the next episode of
the Mandalorian Wikileaks bye everybody
can't wait bye
foreign
[Music]